keisha we need to know absolutely
everything about your performance
alongside drake and the other canadian
icon ah yes i took the stage for the
road to obo fest tours all canadian
north star's event at history and
received the sweetest introduction i
have to personally introduce her
this is my first girlfriend i ever had
in my life
a real legend somebody i love all my
heart
make some noise for keisha
[Applause]
[Music]
okay um we had all the fields there what
was it like getting that introduction
from drake and then stepping on that
stage again oh my gosh it was
the most meaningful memorable sweetest
introduction i've ever been given in my
entire career and a complete full circle
moment honestly because we dreamed of
moments like this to
now have them is i mean means the world
so yeah it was awesome it would be so
emotional like that how did it feel to
have also your fans screaming your songs
back in your face because you're
performing on stage well i started my
career when i was 13 so these are songs
that i wrote when i was 14 15 and even
my voice then was super young so to go
on stage at 34 years old and see these
people knowing every single word still
goosebumps yeah it was amazing it was so
great and talk about canadian icons how
did it feel to be performing with a
roster of all these amazing canadian
artists oh my gosh this was the first
time i'd ever seen everybody come
together in this genuine
meaningful way nobody was competing
nobody was too busy we all made the time
for this moment and it just felt like
the most unity i'd ever seen but it was
so meaningful that's amazing and nelly
furtado i mean yeah did you know that
she was going to be making a surprise
appearance i knew she was going to be
there but i didn't know she was going to
pop up and then when she did like i die
it was so great yeah now drake had to
end the long weekend with some kind of
unfortunate news for young money fans
yeah he announced on instagram on monday
that he was truly devastated to say that
he tested positive for covet and will be
rescheduling the young money show to the
soonest state and of course we all wish
him a speedy recovery